Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode involves crimes against children and won't be suitable for all listeners. Edvard Tradi lived in the Czech Republic town of Kurim. On Monday May 7 2007, Eduard was home alone making some last minute preparations. His partner had recently given birth and Eduard
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的电话号码，请查看您手机应用或我们网站上的节目说明。今天的节目涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。爱德华·特鲁迪住在捷克共和国的库里姆镇。2007年5月7日星期一，爱德华独自在家做最后的准备工作。他的伴侣刚生完孩子，爱德华
was trying to set up a baby monitor before she and their baby daughter were discharged from hospital. At around 11am, Eduard connected the device to his television. He scanned the channel selector, waiting for the live feed from the monitor's video camera to show on the screen. An image did appear, but it wasn't coming from inside Edward's home. The baby monitor had intercepted another camera's signal. The black and white feed on the television showed a young boy who Edward didn't know. He appeared content as he sat naked on a concrete floor playing with a roll of duct tape. Believing the baby monitor had a technical fault, Edward set it aside and carried on with his day.
正试图在妻子和刚出生的女儿出院前安装好婴儿监视器。大约上午11点，爱德华将设备连接到电视上。他扫描了频道选择器，等待监视器摄像头的实时画面出现在屏幕上。画面确实出现了，但并不是来自爱德华的家中。婴儿监视器拦截了另一个摄像头的信号。电视上的黑白画面显示了一个爱德华不认识的小男孩。他看起来很满足，赤身裸体地坐在水泥地上，玩着一卷胶带。爱德华以为婴儿监视器有技术故障，便把它放在一边，继续忙他的一天。
He returned to it later to try again, but it intercepted the same feed from earlier. This time, the naked boy was being fed torn pieces of bread by a woman whose face was out of view. Edouard heard her say, here you go, but didn't recognise her voice. It dawned on Edouard that the boy's hands were tied behind his back. Edouard told his partner what he'd seen and they decided that they should notify the authorities. Before doing so, Edou Edward switched on the baby monitor and TV to assess the situation one last time. This time, the boy was clearly hog-tired and licking what appeared to be vomit from the floor. In the summer of 2005, 28-year-old Klara Mauerova was working at a youth centre in the Czech city of Brno.
他后来回来想再试一次，但它拦截的还是之前的同一个画面。这一次，那个赤身裸体的男孩正在被一个看不见脸的女人喂食撕碎的面包。爱德华听到她说“给你”，但他认不出她的声音。爱德华突然意识到，男孩的双手被反绑在身后。爱德华告诉了他的伴侣他所看到的一切，他们决定应该通知当局。在此之前，爱德华打开了婴儿监视器和电视，想最后评估一下情况。这一次，男孩显然被捆绑着，正在舔食地上看起来像是呕吐物的东西。2005年夏天，28岁的克拉拉·毛罗娃在捷克布尔诺市的一家青年中心工作。
The centre was run by her older sister, Katerina, who approached Klara one day to discuss a child who had just arrived from Norway. Her name was Anichka. She was around 12 years old, sickly, and in need of special foster care. Katerina believed her sister would make an ideal foster mother for the girl. It wasn't an unusual thought. Klara Malarova was successfully raising her sons, 7-year-old Yakub and 5-year-old Andrei, as a single mother. The boys attended the same youth centre where their mother worked, participating in games, sporting activities and language studies. Energetic and sporty, Andrei loved hockey.
该中心由她的姐姐卡特琳娜经营。一天，卡特琳娜找到克拉拉，商量一个刚从挪威来的孩子。她的名字叫阿尼奇卡。她大约12岁，体弱多病，需要特殊的寄养照顾。卡特琳娜认为她的妹妹会成为这个女孩理想的寄养母亲。这并不是一个不寻常的想法。克拉拉·毛罗娃作为单身母亲，成功地抚养着她的两个儿子：7岁的雅库布和5岁的安德烈。男孩们在他们母亲工作的同一个青年中心参加游戏、体育活动和语言学习。安德烈精力充沛，热爱运动，尤其喜欢曲棍球。
His older brother, Yakub, played basketball as well as the flute. He was an avid reader who was especially fond of dinosaurs. Clara's other sister, Gabriela, spent time with the family at least twice a week. She described her nephews as sweethearts and Clara as a great mother and a role model. Working at the youth centre had fostered Clara's interest in child education and she was in the process of gaining professional teaching qualifications. Balancing studies with everyday life wasn't easy. Jakub and Andrei often had to accompany their mother on her class field trips.
他的哥哥雅库布不仅打篮球，还会吹长笛。他是一个狂热的读者，特别喜欢恐龙。克拉拉的另一个姐妹加布里埃拉每周至少两次与他们一家待在一起。她形容她的侄子们是甜心，而克拉拉是一位伟大的母亲和榜样。在青年中心工作培养了克拉拉对儿童教育的兴趣，她正在考取专业的教师资格证。平衡学习和日常生活并不容易。雅库布和安德烈经常不得不陪母亲去参加班级实地考察。
They'd also hang around campus, quietly entertaining themselves while Clara completed her assignments. It was chaotic, but life was good and the boys were happy. Clara's university supervisor, who had met Jakub and Andrei many times, noted that Clara was raising her boys beautifully. After Clara's sister told her about Anichka, Clara went to meet the girl. She found her painting in the woods by the youth centre. Anichka was short and very thin, with mousy brown hair and glasses. She spoke quietly and nervously in a mixture of Czech and Norwegian. While she didn't reveal much about herself, Clara could tell that the girl was severely
他们也会在校园里闲逛，安静地自娱自乐，而克拉拉则完成她的作业。虽然生活混乱，但日子过得不错，孩子们也很开心。克拉拉的大学导师多次见过雅库布和安德烈，他指出克拉拉把孩子们教养得很好。在克拉拉的姐姐告诉她关于阿尼奇卡的事后，克拉拉去见了那个女孩。她发现她在青年中心旁的树林里画画。阿尼奇卡个子矮小，非常瘦弱，留着棕色的鼠灰色头发，戴着眼镜。她用捷克语和挪威语混合着安静而紧张地说话。虽然她没有透露太多关于自己的信息，但克拉拉能看出这个女孩受到了严重的
traumatised. Clara spent the next few weeks building a rapport with Anichka, who eventually opened up about her past. Following the death of her parents, Anichka was placed in an orphanage where she was mistreated by those who ran the facility. Eventually, Anichka, along with some other children, had been sold into a pedophile ring and endured horrendous acts of sexual abuse and torture. She had also been forced to participate in the torture of the other children. When the pedophile ring was finally exposed, Anichka was sent to Katerina Maurova's Centre for Children, as she had no parents or guardians to claim her. Anichka was being treated by Andrei Zainalov, a psychiatric doctor from Azerbaijan who specialised in helping children with traumatic histories. He allowed Clara to take a look at Anichka's medical file
创伤。接下来的几周，克拉拉与阿尼奇卡建立了融洽的关系，阿尼奇卡最终敞开心扉谈论了她的过去。父母去世后，阿尼奇卡被送进了一家孤儿院，在那里她受到了管理人员的虐待。最终，阿尼奇卡和其他一些孩子一起被卖给了一个恋童癖团伙，遭受了可怕的性虐待和折磨。她还被迫参与折磨其他孩子。当恋童癖团伙最终被曝光时，阿尼奇卡被送到了卡特琳娜·毛罗娃的儿童中心，因为没有父母或监护人来认领她。阿尼奇卡正在接受来自阿塞拜疆的精神科医生安德烈·扎纳洛夫的治疗，他专门帮助有创伤史的儿童。他允许克拉拉查看阿尼奇卡的医疗档案。
Dr Zainalov explained that in addition to her psychological traumas, Anichka also had leukaemia In his opinion, she would be lucky if she lived to the age of 16 From around September 2005, Anichka began living with Clara full-time. As part of this new arrangement, Clara's sister, Katerina, took Anichka to the hospital for chemotherapy sessions. Dr Zainalov continued to treat Anichka remotely, sending therapy and care instructions to Clara via email and text messages. It wasn't long before Clara wanted to formally adopt Anichka. Twelve months later, in October 2006, Clara and Katerina Maurova sat in the office of Brunez Deputy Ombudsman. Katerina had used her standing as
扎纳洛夫医生解释说，除了心理创伤外，阿尼奇卡还患有白血病。在他看来，她如果能活到16岁就算幸运了。从2005年9月左右开始，阿尼奇卡开始全职与克拉拉住在一起。作为这项新安排的一部分，克拉拉的姐姐卡特琳娜带阿尼奇卡去医院进行化疗。扎纳洛夫医生继续远程治疗阿尼奇卡，通过电子邮件和短信向克拉拉发送治疗和护理说明。没过多久，克拉拉就想正式收养阿尼奇卡。十二个月后，即2006年10月，克拉拉和卡特琳娜·毛罗娃坐在布尔诺副监察员的办公室里。卡特琳娜利用她作为
the director of a youth centre to arrange the meeting. The sisters explained that they had spent the previous year doing everything they could to have Anichka adopted by Clara. Unfortunately, their efforts were hindered due to the fact that Anichka didn't possess a birth certificate or passport. Without legal identification, it was almost impossible for Clara to adopt Anichka. The sisters had approached multiple institutions seeking help, but no one was willing or able to assist them. was willing or able to assist them. One was the Endangered Children Fund, a non-government, non-profit organisation that provided social and legal protection to children in the Czech Republic. In order to receive their help, Anichka needed to stay at the fund's children's shelter while her case progressed. Given Anichka's traumatic history and ill health,
青年中心主任的身份安排了这次会面。姐妹俩解释说，她们在过去的一年里尽了一切努力让克拉拉收养阿尼奇卡。不幸的是，由于阿尼奇卡没有出生证明或护照，她们的努力受阻。没有合法的身份证明，克拉拉几乎不可能收养阿尼奇卡。姐妹俩曾接触过多家机构寻求帮助，但没有人愿意或能够协助她们。其中一家是濒危儿童基金会，这是一个为捷克共和国的儿童提供社会和法律保护的非政府、非营利组织。为了获得他们的帮助，阿尼奇卡需要在基金会的儿童收容所居住，同时处理她的案件。考虑到阿尼奇卡的创伤史和健康状况，
Clara and Katerina expressed their concern that such an upheaval could have devastating effects. From a procedural standpoint, the deputy ombudsman should have referred Anichka's case to departmental social workers. However, she agreed that removing Anichka's case to departmental social workers. However, she agreed that removing Anichka from her foster family was not in her best interests. The deputy ombudsman provided the Mauarova sisters with advice on how to proceed. The first step was for Anichka's age to be verified. Over the course of several weeks, Katerina accompanied Anichka to University Hospital in Brno, where she was subjected to various medical examinations. X-rays of her forearm and hands were taken, and her DNA was also tested.
克拉拉和卡特琳娜表示担心这种变动可能会产生毁灭性的影响。从程序上讲，副监察员本应将阿尼奇卡的案件移交给部门社会工作者。然而，她同意将阿尼奇卡从寄养家庭中带走并不符合她的最大利益。副监察员为毛罗娃姐妹提供了如何进行的建议。第一步是核实阿尼奇卡的年龄。在接下来的几周里，卡特琳娜陪同阿尼奇卡前往布尔诺大学医院，在那里她接受了各种医学检查。医生拍摄了她前臂和手部的X光片，并对她的DNA进行了检测。
It was determined that Anichka was between the ages of 13 and 14. Armed with a medical certificate confirming Anichka's age, the Maurova sisters applied to Brunez Municipal Court. They sought a judicial ruling on whether Anichka could remain with Clara and be legally adopted by her. The hearing was scheduled for March the following year of 2007. As part of the court process, social workers inspected Clara's small flat in Brunet. They found everything to be in order. They found everything to be in order. By January, Klara had moved her family into a larger two-storey terraced house on a quiet street in Kurim, 15 kilometres north of Brno. The house was arranged and paid for by Anichka's doctor, Andrey Zanarlov, with the help of Klara's sister, Katerina.
经确定，阿尼奇卡的年龄在13到14岁之间。拿着确认阿尼奇卡年龄的医疗证明，毛罗娃姐妹向布尔诺市法院提出了申请。她们寻求司法裁决，以确定阿尼奇卡是否可以留在克拉拉身边并被她合法收养。听证会定于次年2007年3月举行。作为法庭程序的一部分，社会工作者检查了克拉拉在布尔诺的小公寓。他们发现一切井井有条。到1月份，克拉拉已将家人搬到了库里姆一条安静街道上的一栋更大的两层联排别墅里，该地位于布尔诺以北15公里处。这栋房子是由阿尼奇卡的医生安德烈·扎纳洛夫在克拉拉的姐姐卡特琳娜的帮助下安排并支付的。
Klara made sure that Anichka felt at home, painting her room bright yellow and filling it with toys. Anichka's case was heard in the municipal court on March 26. The presiding judge reviewed all the relevant medical and social work documents, as well as some additional reports Katerina had commissioned in support of Klara's application. Both sisters provided statements and Anichka was interviewed by the judge. In reaching her decision, the judge concluded that Anichka's biological mother was likely a drug addict who had given birth to Anichka at home. As Anichka had never attended school, it was unlikely there were any formal records in her name. The judge granted Anichka the legal birth date of December 2 1993, making her 13 years, 3 months and 24 days old. A birth certificate would be created and Anichka finally had legal recognition. Klara's application for adoption was also approved.
克拉拉确保阿尼奇卡感到宾至如归，将她的房间漆成明亮的黄色，并摆满了玩具。阿尼奇卡的案件于3月26日在市法院审理。主审法官审查了所有相关的医疗和社会工作文件，以及卡特琳娜为支持克拉拉的申请而委托撰写的一些额外报告。姐妹俩都提供了陈述，法官也对阿尼奇卡进行了询问。在做出决定时，法官得出结论，阿尼奇卡的亲生母亲很可能是一名吸毒者，在家中生下了阿尼奇卡。由于阿尼奇卡从未上过学，因此不太可能有以她名义登记的正式记录。法官授予阿尼奇卡1993年12月2日的法定出生日期，使她当时为13岁3个月零24天大。出生证明将被制作出来，阿尼奇卡终于获得了法律认可。克拉拉的收养申请也获得了批准。
Anichka was given Klara's surname, Maurova. Six weeks later, on Monday May 7 2007, a call was placed to the Kurim police. The caller was a local man named Eduard Trudy. He had been attempting to connect a baby monitor to his television when it intercepted another camera. Its footage showed a naked boy hogtied on a concrete floor. Edouard had started recording the live feed to preserve evidence, which he then showed police when they arrived at his house. Given the operating range of the baby monitor was only about 30 to 50 metres, police believed the boy must be in a neighbouring house. As one officer focused on the footage, he recognised a song playing in the background.
阿尼奇卡随了克拉拉的姓氏，毛罗娃。六周后，即2007年5月7日星期一，库里姆警方接到了一通电话。打电话的人是当地一名叫爱德华·特鲁迪的男子。他当时正试图将婴儿监视器连接到电视上，结果拦截到了另一个摄像头。画面显示一个赤身裸体的男孩被捆绑在水泥地上。爱德华开始录制实时画面以保存证据，并在警察到达他家时向他们展示了这些证据。考虑到婴儿监视器的有效范围只有30到50米左右，警方认为男孩一定在邻居家。当一名警官专注于画面时，他认出了背景中播放的一首歌。
Realising that if they knew which house the music was coming from, they might find the boy, the officers turned down the television's audio. They then pressed their ears to cups they held against the walls. The cups amplified sound, allowing them to hear noises from the houses that shared a wall with Edouard's home. Emanating from behind one wall was the same song that was captured in the footage. Edouard wasn't familiar with the neighbours on that side and had never seen any boys coming in or out of their house. Officers attended the property and two women aged in their 30s answered the front door.
意识到如果他们知道音乐是从哪栋房子传出来的，他们就能找到那个男孩，警官们调低了电视的音量。然后，他们把杯子贴在墙上，用耳朵贴着杯子听。杯子放大了声音，让他们能听到与爱德华家共用一堵墙的房子里传出的声音。从一堵墙后传出的正是画面中捕捉到的那首歌。爱德华对那一侧的邻居并不熟悉，也从未见过有男孩进出他们的房子。警官们前往该房产，两名30多岁的女性开了前门。
They refused police requests to enter the premises. Although the officers didn't have a search warrant, the situation was exceptional. Ignoring the women's protests, the police forced their way in and came across a storage cupboard beneath a staircase. It was padlocked. The women insisted that no one was in there, but refused to hand over a key. They had to be pulled away from the cupboard as police began trying to remove the padlock. Suddenly, a young girl in pyjamas ran into the room, screaming, Mama! Mama!
她们拒绝了警方进入屋内的要求。虽然警官没有搜查令，但情况特殊。警察无视女人们的抗议，强行闯入，发现楼梯下有一个储物柜。柜子被锁上了。女人们坚称里面没有人，但拒绝交出钥匙。当警察开始试图拆除挂锁时，她们不得不被拉开。突然，一个穿着睡衣的小女孩跑进房间，尖叫着：“妈妈！妈妈！”
After hugging one of the women, the girl started holding onto the officer's legs, hindering their efforts to access the locked cupboard. The padlock was eventually removed and the cupboard opened. Inside was a dark room, about 2 metres by 2 metres in size. It had no ventilation and an odour of vomit and faeces wafted out. A bucket sat in one corner. There was little else aside from a high-tech security camera that was actively recording the space. Next door, Edouard Trudy's eyes were glued to his television. When police had begun knocking at his neighbour's door, the footage of the little boy had abruptly gone dark.
在拥抱了其中一名女性后，女孩开始抱住警官的腿，阻碍他们打开锁着的柜子。挂锁最终被拆除，柜子被打开了。里面是一个大约2米乘2米的黑暗房间。它没有通风，散发着呕吐物和粪便的气味。角落里放着一个桶。除了一个正在录制空间的监控摄像头外，几乎没有其他东西。隔壁，爱德华·特鲁迪的眼睛紧盯着电视。当警察开始敲邻居的门时，小男孩的画面突然变黑了。
Someone had suddenly turned off a light within the confined space. Now that a door had been opened, light filtered back in. Edouard watched live as it illuminated the naked, restrained boy. Police scooped him up, removed his restraints and took him to a waiting ambulance. took him to a waiting ambulance. The boy's name was Andrei and he was seven years old. He told officers that he was kept in the cupboard under the stairs while his mother, Klara Maurova, and his sister, Anichka Maurova, lived freely in the rest of the house. The other woman at the home when police arrived was Andrei's aunt, Katerina Maurova. She visited often. Neither Clara nor Katerina
有人突然关掉了狭小空间里的灯。现在门被打开了，光线又照了进来。爱德华实时看着光线照亮了那个赤身裸体、被束缚的男孩。警察把他抱起来，解开他的束缚，带他上了等候的救护车。男孩名叫安德烈，今年7岁。他告诉警官，他被关在楼梯下的柜子里，而他的母亲克拉拉·毛罗娃和姐姐阿尼奇卡·毛罗娃则在房子的其余部分自由生活。警察到达时家里的另一个女人是安德烈的姨妈卡特琳娜·毛罗娃。她经常来访。克拉拉和卡特琳娜都没有
enquired about Andrei's welfare following his rescue. Clara Maurova was placed under arrest for child abuse and was remanded in custody as an investigation commenced. Klara's other son, nine-year-old Jakub, wasn't at the family home when police stormed the premises. Concerns for his welfare grew, even more so upon the discovery of a locked garden shed in the yard. Gaps in its frame were covered by the same type of duct tape that had been used to bind Andrei's hands and feet. The police broke in, but Yakub was not inside. He was soon located and deemed safe. soon located and deemed safe. As their home life was investigated, Jakub, Andrei, and Anichka were sent to a children's shelter in Brno run by the Endangered Children Fund. During their first day, Anichka remained withdrawn and fearful of social interactions, while her brothers played together and appeared to be adjusting. By the following afternoon, Andre began exhibiting post-traumatic stress and high levels
在安德烈获救后询问过他的安危。克拉拉·毛罗娃因虐待儿童被捕，并在调查开始时被还押候审。克拉拉的另一个儿子，9岁的雅库布，在警察突袭时不在家。人们对他的安危感到担忧，在院子里发现一个锁着的园艺棚后，这种担忧加剧了。棚架上的缝隙被用来捆绑安德烈手脚的同种胶带覆盖着。警察破门而入，但雅库布不在里面。他很快被找到，并被确认安全。在调查他们的家庭生活时，雅库布、安德烈和阿尼奇卡被送往布尔诺一家由濒危儿童基金会运营的儿童收容所。在第一天，阿尼奇卡保持沉默，害怕社交互动，而她的兄弟们在一起玩耍，似乎正在适应。第二天下午，安德烈开始表现出创伤后应激障碍和高度的
of anxiety. He was returned to hospital, where he was stabilised and held for further observation. That evening, staff at the shelter commenced their nightly rounds as the children slept. They found Jakub sound asleep in the room he shared with Anichka, but her bed was empty. A search of the facility failed to locate her. It was soon realised that one of the windows in Anichka's room was open It was not possible for a child to open the window on their own Hundreds of police officers searched for Anichka Mararova. She was known to feel comfortable in the wilderness, so a helicopter with heat-seeking capabilities scoured nearby wooded areas. A spokesperson for the children's shelter publicly voiced concern that Anichka had been kidnapped and said they were worried about her fragile health.
焦虑。他被送回医院，在那里他被稳定下来并留院观察。那天晚上，收容所的工作人员在孩子们睡觉时开始夜间巡视。他们发现雅库布在与阿尼奇卡共用的房间里睡得很香，但她的床是空的。对设施的搜查未能找到她。人们很快意识到阿尼奇卡房间的一扇窗户是开着的。孩子是不可能独自打开那扇窗户的。数百名警察搜寻了阿尼奇卡·毛罗娃。众所周知，她在野外感到舒适，因此一架带有热成像功能的直升机搜查了附近的林区。儿童收容所的发言人公开表示担心阿尼奇卡被绑架，并表示他们担心她脆弱的健康状况。
said they were worried about her fragile health. Meanwhile, with his brother hospitalised and sister missing, nine-year-old Yaqub remained at the children's shelter alone. None of his relatives were permitted to visit him, so he was mostly left to his own devices. As he watched television one day, Yaqub saw the footage of his brother's imprisonment. It had been leaked to the media along with a statement Andre gave police that detailed his ordeal.
与此同时，随着哥哥住院、姐姐失踪，9岁的雅库布独自留在儿童收容所。他的亲戚都不被允许探望他，所以他大部分时间只能自娱自乐。一天，当雅库布看电视时，他看到了他弟弟被囚禁的画面。这些画面连同安德烈给警方的一份详细说明他遭遇的陈述一起被泄露给了媒体。
In his statement, Andre said he'd been abused for a long time in a number of locations and by more people than just his mother. Eventually, Jakub revealed to police that he too had been treated the same way. It all began shortly after Anichka was brought into their home in the autumn of 2005. Klara Maurova cared for Anichka on the instruction and guidance of Anichka's doctor, Andrey Zanarlov. He said that in order for Anichka to heal from her past trauma, she would need to feel completely safe and welcome in Klara's home. Klara had to lavish Anichka with attention, praise and reassurance. with attention, praise and reassurance. Dr Zanarlov also diagnosed Anichka with a condition that caused spinal fluid to build up but could be treated with massage therapy.
在陈述中，安德烈说他在多个地点被虐待了很长时间，而且虐待他的人不仅仅是他的母亲。最终，雅库布向警方透露，他也受到了同样的对待。这一切始于2005年秋天阿尼奇卡被带回家后不久。克拉拉·毛罗娃在阿尼奇卡的医生安德烈·扎纳洛夫的指导下照顾阿尼奇卡。他说，为了让阿尼奇卡从过去的创伤中治愈，她需要感到在克拉拉的家中完全安全和受欢迎。克拉拉必须对阿尼奇卡给予大量的关注、赞美和安慰。扎纳洛夫医生还诊断出阿尼奇卡患有一种导致脊髓液积聚的疾病，但可以通过按摩疗法治疗。
Clara was instructed to regularly massage Anichka's entire body. The doctor explained that massaging Anichka's intimate areas would also desensitise and reprogram her past sexual trauma. Over time, Anichka began to improve. But Clara's efforts to help the young girl had become an obsession. She began neglecting her sons, often sending them to stay with their grandparents. neglecting her sons, often sending them to stay with their grandparents. By the summer of 2006, Clara had been trying to adopt Anichka without success for almost nine months. Meanwhile, Dr Zanarlov was growing concerned about the family situation. Anichka had told him that Andrei and Yakub were being mean to her, and he felt that
克拉拉被指示定期按摩阿尼奇卡的全身。医生解释说，按摩阿尼奇卡的私密部位也可以使她对过去的性创伤脱敏并进行重编程。随着时间的推移，阿尼奇卡开始好转。但克拉拉帮助这个女孩的努力变成了一种痴迷。她开始忽视自己的儿子，经常把他们送到祖父母家住。到2006年夏天，克拉拉尝试收养阿尼奇卡已经快九个月了，但没有成功。与此同时，扎纳洛夫医生开始担心家庭状况。阿尼奇卡告诉他，安德烈和雅库布对她很刻薄，他觉得
she would never truly be a part of the family if they didn't accept her. He recommended that Clara use corporal punishment against her sons to make them behave. Starting in July 2006, Clara dutifully began to beat Andrei and Jakob with a wooden spoon and a metal belt buckle. The boys were also made to kneel for hours at a time or else be locked in a cupboard with no food, water or toilet access. At night, they had to sleep on a mat on the floor. They were completely isolated from family and friends. This abuse continued for around five weeks. Then, Dr Zanarlov advised Clara to bring the boys to a cottage in Vyverska-Batyshka,
如果他们不接受她，她就永远不会真正成为这个家庭的一部分。他建议克拉拉对她的儿子们使用体罚，让他们表现得好一点。从2006年7月开始，克拉拉尽职尽责地开始用木勺和金属皮带扣殴打安德烈和雅库布。男孩们还被迫跪上几个小时，否则就会被关进没有食物、水或厕所的柜子里。晚上，他们必须睡在地板上的垫子上。他们与家人和朋友完全隔绝。这种虐待持续了大约五周。然后，扎纳洛夫医生建议克拉拉把男孩们带到维韦尔斯卡-巴蒂什卡的一间小屋，
a town about 20 kilometres northwest of Brno. There, the re-education would begin. Andre and Jakub arrived at the cottage in late August 2006. It was an isolated property at the end of a small country lane on the outskirts of town. Trees concealed the residents from view. The boy's aunt, Katerina Maurova, was already there when they arrived. She'd brought with her two dog cages, one for each brother. They were locked in the cages, which forced them to remain bent or kneeling
这是一个位于布尔诺西北约20公里的小镇。在那里，再教育将开始。安德烈和雅库布于2006年8月下旬到达小屋。这是一处位于小镇郊区一条乡村小路尽头的偏僻房产。树木遮挡了居民的视线。男孩们的姨妈卡特琳娜·毛罗娃在他们到达时已经在那里了。她带来了两个狗笼，每个兄弟一个。他们被锁在笼子里，被迫保持弯曲或跪着的姿势，
and unable to move. They were only fed scraps of food and were not released to use the bathroom. If they tried to communicate with one another, they were beaten. That night, the first re-education session began. The boys were bound, blindfolded, and beaten. Clara scratched and stabbed her sons with a fork and forced their heads underwater while Katerina held them in place. Andre and Jakub had to memorise vulgar passages and were hurt if they failed to recount them word for word. The torture continued into the next day.
无法移动。他们只被喂食残羹剩饭，也不被允许去洗手间。如果他们试图互相交流，就会遭到殴打。那天晚上，第一次再教育课程开始了。男孩们被捆绑、蒙住眼睛并遭到殴打。克拉拉用叉子抓伤并刺伤她的儿子们，并在卡特琳娜按住他们时强行将他们的头按入水中。安德烈和雅库布必须背诵粗俗的段落，如果不能逐字复述就会受到伤害。折磨一直持续到第二天。
As well as being victimised, Andrei was also made to hurt his brother. But when Anichka accused Andrei of physically harming her, he bore the brunt of the abuse. At one point, Anichka accused Andrei of physically harming her, he bore the brunt of the abuse. At one point, Anichka even joined in. While Dr Andrei Zanarlov wasn't present at the cottage, he kept in touch with Klara via text messages and emails. When Klara informed him that Andrei's re-education was not working, Dr Zanarlov devised a plan. As per the doctor's orders, Clara handed Andrei a glass of water and told him to give it to Yakub, who was thirsty. Andrei did as instructed and Yakub drank from the glass.
除了受害之外，安德烈还被迫伤害他的哥哥。但当阿尼奇卡指责安德烈身体伤害她时，他承受了虐待的重压。有一次，阿尼奇卡甚至参与其中。虽然安德烈·扎纳洛夫医生没有出现在小屋，但他通过短信和电子邮件与克拉拉保持联系。当克拉拉告诉他安德烈的再教育没有奏效时，扎纳洛夫医生制定了一个计划。按照医生的命令，克拉拉递给安德烈一杯水，让他给口渴的雅库布喝。安德烈照做了，雅库布喝了那杯水。
He was then taken away. Yacoub drank from the glass. He was then taken away. Andrei was then informed that the water he had just given his older brother was actually poison. He was led outside to the back of the cottage where Yacoub's lifeless body lay in a freshly dug grave. Andrei was told that if he behaved himself and obeyed all instructions, then Jakub would come back to life. Andre promised to be good and Jakub, who'd been forced to play dead by the adults, got up. reassured Clara that these re-education practices were scientifically proven to be effective in modifying bad behaviour and insisted that the program was nearly complete. His next demand was for Clara to burn Andre's buttocks, cut off a piece of the wounded flesh, and force the young boy to eat it.
然后他被带走了。安德烈随后被告知，他刚才给哥哥喝的水其实是毒药。他被带到小屋后面，那里躺着雅库布毫无生气的尸体，旁边是一个刚挖好的坟墓。安德烈被告知，如果他表现好并服从所有指示，雅库布就会复活。安德烈承诺会表现良好，而被迫被成年人装死的雅库布站了起来。扎纳洛夫医生向克拉拉保证，这些再教育做法在改变不良行为方面已被科学证明是有效的，并坚持认为该计划即将完成。他的下一个要求是让克拉拉烧伤安德烈的臀部，切下一块受伤的肉，并强迫这个小男孩吃掉它。
This was too far for Clara who couldn't carry out the order. Disappointed in her, Dr Zanarlov decided to send out reinforcements. Two men and a woman soon arrived at the cottage. 29-year-old Jan Turek was a scout leader at Katerina Mauerova's Centre for Children. His friend, 23-year-old Jan Szklar, occasionally worked there as an assistant. The woman was 26-year-old Hanna Byshova. She too was a scout leader at the centre. Andrey and Jakub knew her as Aunt Nancy. Klara Maurova handed her sons over to Turek, Shkla and Bashova.
这对克拉拉来说太过分了，她无法执行这个命令。对她感到失望的扎纳洛夫医生决定派出增援部队。两名男子和一名女子很快到达了小屋。29岁的扬·图雷克是卡特琳娜·毛罗娃儿童中心的一名童子军领袖。他的朋友，23岁的扬·什克拉尔，偶尔在那里担任助理。那个女人是26岁的汉娜·比绍娃。她也是该中心的一名童子军领袖。安德烈和雅库布称她为南希姨妈。克拉拉·毛罗娃把她的儿子们交给了图雷克、什克拉尔和比绍娃。
She thanked them for the work they were about to do, then left. Turek and Shkla proceeded to gag, strip, restrain, mutilate and torture the boys, as per Dr. Zanarlov's instructions. Meanwhile, Hanna Bashova made lots of noise in the background to give the boys the impression more people were present. When Clara returned, she knelt beside Andrei and Yakub and said that if they ever told anyone what had happened at the cottage, she would bring them back there. Klara took Anichka back to their Brane flat and continued trying to adopt the girl, while Andrei and Yakub were left with their aunt, Katerina, as well as Hanna Bashova and Jan Shklar. They took the boys to an after-school clubhouse
她感谢他们即将做的工作，然后离开了。图雷克和什克拉尔按照扎纳洛夫医生的指示，开始堵住男孩们的嘴、剥光他们的衣服、束缚、残害并折磨他们。与此同时，汉娜·比绍娃在背景中制造了很大的噪音，给男孩们一种有更多人在场的错觉。当克拉拉回来时，她跪在安德烈和雅库布身边说，如果他们敢告诉任何人小屋里发生的事情，她就会把他们带回那里。克拉拉把阿尼奇卡带回了布尔诺的公寓，继续尝试收养这个女孩，而安德烈和雅库布则留给了他们的姨妈卡特琳娜，以及汉娜·比绍娃和扬·什克拉尔。他们把男孩们带到了一个课后俱乐部，
in Brnoer South, where Katerina, Bashova, and Shklar sometimes worked as group leaders. Andrei and Yakub were kept separate and their abuse continued Their mother never visited and the boys were not allowed to see or speak to other family members On September 10, Andre turned 7 Almost a month later on October 6, Jakub had his 9th birthday Almost a month later on October 6, Jakub had his ninth birthday. Then, four months into the brothers' imprisonment at the clubhouse, things changed. In December, Andrei was allowed to live with his mother and Anichka in their new house in Kurim.
位于布尔诺南部，卡特琳娜、比绍娃和什克拉尔有时在那里担任小组组长。安德烈和雅库布被分开，虐待继续进行。他们的母亲从不探望，男孩们也不被允许见其他家庭成员或与他们交谈。9月10日，安德烈满7岁。近一个月后的10月6日，雅库布过了9岁生日。然后，在兄弟俩被囚禁在俱乐部四个月后，情况发生了变化。12月，安德烈被允许与他的母亲和阿尼奇卡住在库里姆的新家里。
Jakub remained at the clubhouse. As time wore on, he was sometimes permitted to attend school, but was threatened into remaining silent about the abuse. Meanwhile, 15 kilometres away in Kurim, Andre was kept naked and bound in a small, windowless storage cupboard under the stairs. No one suspected anything was wrong in the Mauerova household until May 2007, when neighbour Edouard Thredy connected his baby monitor to his television. André and Jakub's bodies were riddled with burns, scratches, and scars. Both boys exhibited symptoms of post-traumatic stress as well as phobias and other developmental mood and sleep disorders. Their ability to concentrate was impaired and they grappled with feelings of loneliness, isolation, guilt, and abandonment. Psychologists determined that Andre and Jakob would require long-term,
雅库布留在了俱乐部。随着时间的推移，他有时被允许上学，但受到威胁，要求对虐待行为保持沉默。与此同时，15公里外的库里姆，安德烈被赤身裸体地捆绑在楼梯下一个没有窗户的小储物柜里。直到2007年5月，邻居爱德华·特鲁迪将婴儿监视器连接到电视上，才有人怀疑毛罗娃家出了问题。安德烈和雅库布的身上布满了烧伤、抓痕和伤疤。两个男孩都表现出创伤后应激障碍的症状，以及恐惧症和其他发育性情绪和睡眠障碍。他们的注意力集中能力受损，并饱受孤独、孤立、内疚和被遗弃感的折磨。心理学家确定安德烈和雅库布将需要长期的、
if not lifelong, psychological care. Despite what they had endured, the brothers were remarkably resilient. They started school within days of their rescue.rei was homeschooled at the children's shelter while Yakub attended in-person classes. Their older sister, Anichka, didn't cope as well. While she hadn't endured any of the abuse instigated by Dr. Andrei Zanalov, she was very unsettled in the shelter that was supposed to be their refuge. Then she vanished altogether. Nine days later, three identical envelopes arrived at the Brunet Ombudsman's office, the Mladá Frontá Dnes newspaper, and the office of the Czech Republic's president. and the office of the Czech Republic's president.
如果不是终身的心理护理。尽管经历了这些，兄弟俩还是表现出了惊人的韧性。他们在获救几天后就开始上学。安德烈在儿童收容所接受家庭教育，而雅库布则参加了面对面课程。他们的姐姐阿尼奇卡表现得没那么好。虽然她没有遭受安德烈·扎纳洛夫医生煽动的任何虐待，但她在本应是他们避难所的收容所里感到非常不安。然后她彻底消失了。九天后，三个相同的信封寄到了布尔诺监察员办公室、《今日青年阵线》报社以及捷克共和国总统办公室。
Each contained a photocopy of the same nine-page handwritten letter dated six days earlier and signed with the name Anichka Maurova. It read, My mother is not at all bad, as shown on television and in the newspapers. I don't understand everything, but I will write the truth as I know it. Please forgive my mother. I know that the police and everyone are looking for me, but I'm afraid of everyone. Nobody wants to hear how it really was." The letter detailed Anichka's time living with Clara, Andre and Jakub. She insisted that Andre was not abused or locked away.
每个信封里都有一份九页手写信的复印件，日期是六天前，署名为阿尼奇卡·毛罗娃。信中写道：“我的母亲一点也不坏，正如电视和报纸上所说的那样。我不明白所有的事情，但我会写出我所知道的真相。请原谅我的母亲。我知道警察和每个人都在找我，但我害怕所有人。没有人想听事情的真相。”这封信详细描述了阿尼奇卡与克拉拉、安德烈和雅库布住在一起的时间。她坚称安德烈没有受到虐待或被关起来。
She accused Andre of lashing out at her, mostly at night when there was no one around to witness it. He had threatened Anichka to stay quiet, saying that she would be taken away if she spoke up. The letter explained that Clara desperately wanted Andrei to treat Anichka nicely. She feared that his misbehaviour would compromise Anichka's adoption. Upon learning that her adoptive mother could be imprisoned for eight years, Anichka fled the children's shelter. Her letter didn't shed any light on where she was currently. However, postage marks indicated the envelopes were sent from a town just north of Brunei. The country's president expressed scepticism that the letter was penned by a 13-year-old.
她指责安德烈对她大打出手，大多是在晚上没有人在场的时候。他威胁阿尼奇卡保持沉默，说如果她说了出来，她就会被带走。信中解释说，克拉拉非常希望安德烈能善待阿尼奇卡。她担心他的不当行为会危及阿尼奇卡的收养。在得知她的养母可能被监禁八年后，阿尼奇卡逃离了儿童收容所。她的信没有透露她目前的下落。然而，邮戳显示这些信封是从布尔诺以北的一个小镇寄出的。国家总统对这封信是否由一名13岁女孩所写表示怀疑。
Psychologists agreed that an adult had likely helped Anichka write it, then deliver it to the post office. Anichka's former room at the children's shelter in Brno was thoroughly inspected by forensic investigators in an effort to identify the person who had facilitated her escape. They swabbed surfaces and were able to detect foreign DNA which was cross-checked against everyone embroiled in the case. While it wasn't a direct match to anybody involved, it was a familial match to Jan Szkla. He had joined in the abuse of Andrzej and Jakub at the Wawerska-Batyska cottage. The DNA belonged to his older sister, 32-year-old Barbora Szklova.
心理学家一致认为，很可能是一名成年人帮助阿尼奇卡写了这封信，然后将其送到邮局。法医调查人员彻底检查了阿尼奇卡在布尔诺儿童收容所的前房间，试图查明协助她逃跑的人。他们擦拭了表面，并能够检测到外来DNA，这些DNA与所有卷入此案的人进行了交叉比对。虽然它与任何相关人员都不直接匹配，但它是扬·什克拉尔的家族匹配。他曾参与在维韦尔斯卡-巴蒂什卡小屋对安德烈和雅库布的虐待。该DNA属于他的姐姐，32岁的巴尔博拉·什克洛娃。
Like her brother, Barbora Shklova worked at Katerina Maurova's youth centre. The amount of Barbora's DNA found throughout Anichka's room indicated she must have lived there for a number of days. Though Barbora's current whereabouts were unknown, investigators were certain that she was with Anichka Maurova. Anichka Maurova's disappearance was covered extensively in Czech newspapers. Articles featured a photo of a smiling Klara Mauarova with an arm around Anichka's shoulders. Anichka's brown hair was parted down the middle, with each half woven into thin braids.
像她的弟弟一样，巴尔博拉·什克洛娃在卡特琳娜·毛罗娃的青年中心工作。在阿尼奇卡房间里发现的巴尔博拉的DNA数量表明她一定在那里住过几天。虽然巴尔博拉目前的下落不明，但调查人员确信她和阿尼奇卡·毛罗娃在一起。阿尼奇卡·毛罗娃的失踪在捷克报纸上得到了广泛报道。文章刊登了一张克拉拉·毛罗娃微笑着搂着阿尼奇卡肩膀的照片。阿尼奇卡的棕色头发从中间分开，每一半都编成了细辫子。
She looked nervous, with an emotionless face and downward gaze. Upon seeing this photograph, a staff member at Katerina Maurova's youth centre phoned the police. She reported that the person next to Klara Maurova was not a teenage girl named Anichka. She was actually a woman who had worked at the centre for the last seven years. Her name was Barbora Shklova. who had worked at the centre for the last seven years. Her name was Barbora Shklova. Barbora Shklova was the eldest of three children. Her mother was a doctor who had a severe drinking problem and her father was mostly absent,
她看起来很紧张，表情麻木，目光向下。看到这张照片后，卡特琳娜·毛罗娃青年中心的一名工作人员给警方打了电话。她报告说，克拉拉·毛罗娃旁边的人不是一个叫阿尼奇卡的十几岁女孩。她实际上是一个在中心工作了七年的女人。她的名字叫巴尔博拉·什克洛娃。巴尔博拉·什克洛娃是三个孩子中的老大。她的母亲是一名有严重酗酒问题的医生，而她的父亲大部分时间都不在，
choosing to prioritise his work as a boys' youth group leader. Barbora found solace in nature as she generally felt uncomfortable around people. Growing up, she was treated for neurological and cardiac conditions as well as epilepsy. She also had an underactive thyroid which inhibited her physical growth. No matter her age, Barbora had a tendency to form childlike attachments to others. When Barbora was in her early 20s, she met Katerina Maurova. The young women became friends and eventually moved in together. At 26, Barbora started work as an educator at the youth centre Katerina ran.
选择优先考虑他作为男孩青年组负责人的工作。巴尔博拉在大自然中找到了慰藉，因为她通常在人际交往中感到不自在。在成长过程中，她接受了神经系统和心脏疾病以及癫痫的治疗。她还患有甲状腺功能减退症，这抑制了她的身体发育。无论年龄多大，巴尔博拉都有对他人形成孩子般依恋的倾向。当巴尔博拉20多岁出头时，她遇到了卡特琳娜·毛罗娃。这两个年轻女人成为了朋友，最终住在一起。26岁时，巴尔博拉开始在卡特琳娜经营的青年中心担任教育工作者。
Barbora's younger brother Jan was also hired sometime later. In 2005, with the assistance of Katerina Maurova, Barbora began creating a new identity for herself as a 13-year-old named Anichka. They invented a backstory for the fictional Anichka, one so traumatic it would elicit compassion from others and be difficult to disprove. passion from others and be difficult to disprove. Barbora spent months starving herself until she lost half her weight and had the appearance of a sickly teen. She wore children's clothing, hats and colourful eyeglasses and styled her hair in ways popular with teens. Then, in the summer of 2005, Katerina introduced Anichka to her younger sister, Klara. For the next two years, Barbora played the role of Anichka to perfection. The stories about her deceased parents, time spent in an orphanage, and the abuse by a pedophile ring were all made up, as was her leukaemia diagnosis.
巴尔博拉的弟弟扬后来也被雇佣了。2005年，在卡特琳娜·毛罗娃的协助下，巴尔博拉开始为自己创造一个13岁女孩阿尼奇卡的身份。他们为虚构的阿尼奇卡编造了一个背景故事，这个故事非常悲惨，足以引起他人的同情，且难以反驳。巴尔博拉花了几个月的时间节食，直到她减掉了一半的体重，看起来像一个病态的青少年。她穿着儿童服装、帽子和色彩鲜艳的眼镜，并以青少年流行的方式梳理头发。然后，在2005年夏天，卡特琳娜将阿尼奇卡介绍给了她的妹妹克拉拉。在接下来的两年里，巴尔博拉完美地扮演了阿尼奇卡的角色。关于她已故父母、在孤儿院度过的时光以及被恋童癖团伙虐待的故事都是编造的，她的白血病诊断也是如此。
Katerina gave Klara fake medical documentation to support Anichka's cancer diagnosis. She would regularly collect barbora from Klara's home, claiming she was taking Anichka to chemotherapy. Although she never attended the hospital, Barbora would return looking weak, wrapped in a blanket with tubes sticking out of her. Anichka's psychiatrist, Dr Andrei Zanarlov from Azerbaijan didn't exist either. While never conclusively established, it was thought that Barbora's younger brother Jan Shklar played this role. He had disguised himself and produced fraudulent credentials when meeting Clara. Anitska's medical file that he let her read was also fake
卡特琳娜给了克拉拉虚假的医疗文件来支持阿尼奇卡的癌症诊断。她会定期从克拉拉家接走巴尔博拉，声称带阿尼奇卡去化疗。虽然她从未去过医院，但巴尔博拉回来时总是显得虚弱，裹着毯子，身上插着管子。阿尼奇卡的心理医生，来自阿塞拜疆的安德烈·扎纳洛夫医生也不存在。虽然从未最终确定，但人们认为巴尔博拉的弟弟扬·什克拉尔扮演了这个角色。他在见到克拉拉时伪装了自己并出示了伪造的证件。他让克拉拉阅读的阿尼奇卡的医疗档案也是假的。
The deputy ombudsman who assisted the Mauerova sisters, the doctors who examined Anichka and submitted reports to the court and the judge who gave Anichka a legal identity and formalised her adoption were all deceived as well The judge had made her decision based on false medical reports. The doctors who examined Anichka took x-rays and samples of her DNA and had correctly determined that their patient was between the ages of 13 and 14. However, their patient had not been Barbora Shklova masquerading as Anichka. Katerina had duped a friend and used his 13-year-old daughter to impersonate Anichka during the assessment. Clara was aware of this specific con and went along with it, based on the guidance of Dr Andrey Zanarlov.
协助毛罗娃姐妹的副监察员、检查阿尼奇卡并向法院提交报告的医生，以及授予阿尼奇卡合法身份并正式确定其收养关系的法官，也都受到了欺骗。法官是根据虚假的医疗报告做出的决定。检查阿尼奇卡的医生拍摄了X光片并采集了她的DNA样本，并正确地确定了他们的病人年龄在13到14岁之间。然而，他们的病人并不是伪装成阿尼奇卡的巴尔博拉·什克洛娃。卡特琳娜欺骗了一位朋友，并利用他13岁的女儿在评估期间冒充阿尼奇卡。克拉拉知道这个具体的骗局，并在安德烈·扎纳洛夫医生的指导下配合了它。
He explained that if the real Anichka attended the examination, then doctors would discover her leukaemia and the adoption application would be immediately rejected. All of the emails and text messages from Dr Zanarlov to Klara were later found to have originated from accounts belonging to Katerina Maurova. Every instruction to abuse Andrey and Yakub had come from their own aunt. Barbora Shklova, as Anichka, abetted the abuse by saying the brothers were harming her. Klara Maurova insisted that she was completely oblivious to the web of deceit woven by her sister. She was unaware that her cancer-stricken teenage daughter was in fact a woman in her early 30s.
他解释说，如果真正的阿尼奇卡参加检查，医生就会发现她的白血病，收养申请会被立即拒绝。后来发现，扎纳洛夫医生发给克拉拉的所有电子邮件和短信都源自属于卡特琳娜·毛罗娃的账户。虐待安德烈和雅库布的每一条指令都来自他们自己的姨妈。巴尔博拉·什克洛娃作为阿尼奇卡，通过声称兄弟俩在伤害她来教唆虐待。克拉拉·毛罗娃坚称她完全不知道她姐姐编织的欺骗之网。她不知道她那个患有癌症的十几岁女儿实际上是一个30出头的女人。
In a media statement, Clara said, All my actions of which I am accused were led and directed by other persons whose identity was kept secret from me and who at the same time took advantage of my very bad mental state into which they brought me and in which they kept me. Clara was supported by her parents and other sister, Gabriela, who condemned Katerina. They claimed that Katerina, both directly and via the fictional doctor, had kept Clara in a constant state of fear. Clara was led to believe that if she didn't follow the orders of those she trusted, Anichka would die. Klara Maurova, quote, Until the last moment, I believed that the doctor would show up and everything would be explained.
在媒体声明中，克拉拉说：“我被指控的所有行为都是在其他人的引导和指示下进行的，他们的身份对我保密，同时他们利用了我当时极度糟糕的精神状态，并将我困在这种状态中。”克拉拉得到了她父母和另一个姐妹加布里埃拉的支持，她们谴责了卡特琳娜。她们声称，卡特琳娜无论是直接还是通过虚构的医生，都让克拉拉一直处于恐惧之中。克拉拉被误导相信，如果她不听从那些她信任的人的命令，阿尼奇卡就会死。克拉拉·毛罗娃引用道：“直到最后一刻，我仍然相信医生会出现，一切都会得到解释。”
That I was just helping Anichka and that it made sense. I have nothing now. I just hurt my kids terribly and ruined their lives. In the weeks and months after Andrei and Yakub were rescued, those responsible for their suffering were located and arrested. responsible for their suffering were located and arrested. The boy's mother and their aunt faced abuse and torture charges, as did Centre for Children's staff members Jan Turek, Jan Szkla, and Hanna Baszova. However, Barbora Szklova was still missing. The last anyone had heard of her was the letter she'd sent to the country's president, deputy ombudsman, and a national newspaper, while still masquerading as a Nijka.
“我只是在帮助阿尼奇卡，这很有道理。我现在一无所有。我只是严重伤害了我的孩子们，毁了他们的生活。”在安德烈和雅库布获救后的几周和几个月里，那些应对他们的痛苦负责的人被定位并逮捕。男孩的母亲和他们的姨妈面临虐待和酷刑指控，儿童中心的工作人员扬·图雷克、扬·什克拉尔和汉娜·巴绍娃也面临同样的指控。然而，巴尔博拉·什克洛娃仍然下落不明。最后一次有人听到她的消息是她写给国家总统、副监察员和一家全国性报纸的信，当时她仍然伪装成阿尼奇卡。
On Friday June 15, nearly five weeks after she had fled the shelter, Barbora Shklova showed up at the Czech embassy in the Danish capital of Copenhagen. She was accompanied by her father, their lawyer, and two journalists. Barbora had been laying low in the city for about a month. At the embassy, she provided ID and requested that hair and saliva samples be taken in order to prove that she was Barbora Shklova. After Barbora and her entourage left, embassy staff contacted the authorities in the Czech Republic. Despite her stated fear of people and the media,
6月15日星期五，在逃离收容所近五周后，巴尔博拉·什克洛娃出现在位于丹麦首都哥本哈根的捷克大使馆。她由她的父亲、他们的律师和两名记者陪同。巴尔博拉在城里躲藏了大约一个月。在大使馆，她提供了身份证件，并要求采集头发和唾液样本，以证明她就是巴尔博拉·什克洛娃。在巴尔博拉和她的随行人员离开后，大使馆工作人员联系了捷克共和国当局。尽管她声称害怕人群和媒体，
Barbora arranged an interview with the Lidove Novine newspaper. She admitted to her fictitious life as a nichka. She felt happier and more comfortable being a nichka and preferred the way people treated her when they thought she was young. Barbora said that the original intention behind the con was to supervise the children at Katerina Maurova's youth centre while blending in with them. The situation then, quote, evolved to her inserting herself into Clara Maurova's life and family. She didn't elaborate any further. Barbora denied that Clara abused her sons. She claimed that Andre had only been locked up for a short time on the day he was discovered and was disciplined on
巴尔博拉安排了《人民报》的采访。她承认了自己作为阿尼奇卡的虚构生活。她觉得作为阿尼奇卡更快乐、更自在，并且更喜欢人们在认为她年轻时对待她的方式。巴尔博拉说，这场骗局最初的意图是在卡特琳娜·毛罗娃的青年中心监督孩子们，同时融入他们。情况随后“演变成她介入了克拉拉·毛罗娃的生活和家庭”。她没有再做进一步阐述。巴尔博拉否认克拉拉虐待了她的儿子。她声称安德烈只是在被发现的那天被关了一小段时间，并且在
just one other occasion. Barbora held little sympathy for Andre, implying that his punishment was rightly deserved. When pressed on that point, Barbora claimed that the then six-year-old Andrei had beaten both her and Yakub. She couldn't explain what prompted the attack, only that Andrei had suddenly started shouting, kill Yakub, kill Anichka. Barbora remarked, Jakub, kill Anichka. Barbora remarked, Andre has such power that no one would believe it. He has enormous power. Barbora had no plans to return to the Czech Republic, saying that she would provide the authorities with a statement through her lawyer. When asked if she would continue being Anichka, Barbora said, no, Anichka's gone.
仅有的一次其他场合受到过管教。巴尔博拉对安德烈几乎没有同情心，暗示他的惩罚是罪有应得。当被追问这一点时，巴尔博拉声称当时六岁的安德烈曾殴打她和雅库布。她无法解释是什么引发了袭击，只说安德烈突然开始大喊：“杀了雅库布，杀了阿尼奇卡。”巴尔博拉评论道：“安德烈有种力量，没人会相信。他有巨大的力量。”巴尔博拉没有返回捷克共和国的计划，称她将通过律师向当局提供一份声明。当被问及她是否会继续做阿尼奇卡时，巴尔博拉说：“不，阿尼奇卡已经走了。”
After this interview, Barbora Shklova disappeared again. Five months later, in December 2007, a 13-year-old boy named Adam Varner, who lived in Oslo, Norway, approached his schoolteachers and confided that he had been abused. Believing the perpetrator was Adam's father, Adam was sent to a children's shelter. Then on Sunday December 16, Adam vanished. Police were contacted and a nationwide search began. Adam Barna was eventually located in the Czech Republic, where he was found safe and well with his mother. Adam had never attended school in Norway. Teachers 600 kilometres away in Oslo had no idea that the 13-year-old boy they thought was Adam Fahner was in fact 33-year-old Barbora Shklova.
这次采访后，巴尔博拉·什克洛娃再次消失。五个月后的2007年12月，一名住在挪威奥斯陆的13岁男孩亚当·瓦纳找到他的老师，吐露自己受到了虐待。由于认为施暴者是亚当的父亲，亚当被送往儿童收容所。随后在12月16日星期日，亚当失踪了。警方接到通知，全国范围的搜寻开始了。亚当·巴纳最终在捷克共和国被找到，他与母亲在一起，平安无事。亚当从未在挪威上过学。600公里外奥斯陆的老师们根本不知道，他们以为是亚当·法纳的13岁男孩，实际上是33岁的巴尔博拉·什克洛娃。
She had stolen Adam's identity and had been masquerading as him for several months. To appear more masculine, Barbora had gained weight, shaved her head, and dressed in loose-fitting, oversized clothes favoured by teenage boys. According to the school's principal, some teachers thought Adam looked more like a girl, but they attributed this to 13 being a tricky age. Barbora was eventually tracked down north of Oslo and arrested. She was transported back to the Czech Republic, where she was photographed being led into a police station clutching a children's book and teddy bear. led into a police station clutching a children's book and teddy bear. Barbora was charged for the abuse of Andre and Jakub. The prosecution and defence had Barbora examined by their own experts.
她窃取了亚当的身份，并伪装成他好几个月。为了看起来更男性化，巴尔博拉增重、剃光头，并穿着十几岁男孩喜欢的宽松大码衣服。据校长说，一些老师认为亚当看起来更像个女孩，但他们将其归因于13岁是一个棘手的年龄。巴尔博拉最终在奥斯陆北部被追踪到并逮捕。她被押送回捷克共和国，在那里她被拍到紧紧抓着一本儿童读物和一只泰迪熊被带进警察局。巴尔博拉因虐待安德烈和雅库布受到指控。控辩双方都让巴尔博拉接受了各自专家的检查。
The prosecution's expert concluded that Barbora didn't suffer from any psychological conditions. Rather, she was an expert at manipulating the people around her. The defence's expert disagreed, claiming that Barbora was mentally ill and in need of treatment. To resolve the matter, the court ordered its own evaluation. To resolve the matter, the court ordered its own evaluation. Their panel of eight independent psychologists and psychiatrists assessed Barbora and found she had no signs of mental illness. Barbora was declared competent to stand trial, as were her co-accused, Klara Mauorova, Katerina Mauorova, Hanna Bashova, Jan Turek, and Jan Sklar. They had all been charged with the abuse of Andrei and Jakub.
控方的专家得出结论，巴尔博拉没有患任何心理疾病。相反，她是操纵周围人的专家。辩方专家不同意，声称巴尔博拉患有精神疾病，需要治疗。为了解决这个问题，法院下令进行自己的评估。由八名独立心理学家和精神科医生组成的专家组对巴尔博拉进行了评估，发现她没有任何精神疾病的迹象。巴尔博拉被宣布有能力受审，她的共同被告克拉拉·毛罗娃、卡特琳娜·毛罗娃、汉娜·巴绍娃、扬·图雷克和扬·什克拉尔也是如此。他们都被指控虐待安德烈和雅库布。
Klara, Katerina, Hanna Bashova, and Jan Sklar were charged with deprivation of liberty, and Jan Turek faced an additional charge of causing bodily harm. and Jan Turek faced an additional charge of causing bodily harm. Katarina also faced charges for perjury and providing false expert testimony to court when helping Klara adopt Anichka. The trial opened with a full read of the indictment, which detailed all of the abuse allegedly perpetrated against Andrei and Yakub. At the conclusion of the reading, a noticeably thinner Klara Maurova took to the stand. Sobbing, Klara agreed with everything that had been read from the indictment.
克拉拉、卡特琳娜、汉娜·巴绍娃和扬·什克拉尔被控剥夺自由，扬·图雷克还面临一项造成身体伤害的额外指控。卡特琳娜还面临伪证罪和在帮助克拉拉收养阿尼奇卡时向法院提供虚假专家证词的指控。审判以宣读起诉书开始，详细说明了据称对安德烈和雅库布实施的所有虐待行为。宣读结束后，明显消瘦的克拉拉·毛罗娃走上证人席。克拉拉啜泣着，同意了起诉书中宣读的一切内容。
from the indictment. She claimed that she had put complete faith and trust in Dr. Andrei Zanarlov and her sister, Katerina. Quote, I tried to help Anichka, then the problems with the boys' behavior towards Anichka began. I believed that they were serious and I was convinced that I had spoiled them with my education and actions, that Andrei was behaviourally sick and would not have a normal life. I was grateful to the doctor for offering to help me with my boys. I wanted very much to help Anichka too so that we could be like a family. too so that we could be like a family. I believed that if I did everything right and well, I would save Anichka and Andrei would not have to go to an institution for his bad behaviour and that Jakub would be a good person. Despite claims previously made by Barbora Shklova, Clara admitted that Andrei was almost always locked inside the cupboard under the stairs at their Kurim house.
她声称自己完全信任安德烈·扎纳洛夫医生和她的妹妹卡特琳娜。“我试图帮助阿尼奇卡，然后男孩们对阿尼奇卡的态度问题就开始了。我相信这些问题很严重，我确信是我用我的教育和行为宠坏了他们，安德烈在行为上有病，不会有正常的生活。我很感激医生主动提出帮我照顾我的男孩们。我也非常想帮助阿尼奇卡，这样我们就能像一家人一样。我相信如果我把一切都做得正确且妥当，我就能拯救阿尼奇卡，安德烈就不必因为他的不良行为被送进机构，雅库布也会成为一个好人。”尽管巴尔博拉·什克洛娃之前有此说法，但克拉拉承认安德烈几乎总是被锁在库里姆家中楼梯下的橱柜里。
He was only let out on rare occasions as a reward for good behaviour. Clara's maternal focus was so warped that by the time police banged on her front door to rescue Andre, she actually feared they were there to take Anichka away. In trying to explain her actions, Clara stated, I hurt my children, but I didn't want to hurt them. I tried to be a good mother. I never liked violence. Terrible things happened. I am aware of it and I cannot understand how I could have allowed it. Psychological experts testified that Clara Maurova had a tendency to make decisions based on emotions and feelings alone. They acknowledged that the constant and increasing pressure placed on her caused a, quote, kind of brainwashing. Although they conceded that Clara did not suffer from any
他只有在表现良好时才会被偶尔放出来。克拉拉的母性焦点如此扭曲，以至于当警察敲门营救安德烈时，她实际上担心他们是来带走阿尼奇卡的。在试图解释自己的行为时，克拉拉说：“我伤害了我的孩子，但我不想伤害他们。我努力做一个好母亲。我从不喜欢暴力。可怕的事情发生了。我意识到了这一点，我不明白我怎么能允许它发生。”心理学专家作证说，克拉拉·毛罗娃倾向于仅凭情绪和感觉做决定。他们承认，施加在她身上持续且不断增加的压力导致了一种“洗脑”。尽管他们承认克拉拉没有患上任何
disorders and was able to control her actions, they agreed that she had been deceived, abused, abused and manipulated. Clara was the only defendant who admitted to her actions. The others fully denied the allegations against them. Barbora Shklova testified briefly in person and the rest of her statement was read out by the judge. She stated that she was not a perpetrator of deception or abuse, but a victim of it. She claimed that she had been repeatedly locked up, beaten, tied to tables, sexually abused and cut with knives by the Maurova sisters and Hanna Bashova. Other strangers took part as well. Barbora also claimed that
障碍并且能够控制自己的行为，但他们同意她受到了欺骗、虐待和操纵。克拉拉是唯一承认自己行为的被告。其他人完全否认了对他们的指控。巴尔博拉·什克洛娃亲自作了简短的证词，其余的陈述由法官宣读。她声称自己不是欺骗或虐待的实施者，而是受害者。她声称自己被毛罗娃姐妹和汉娜·巴绍娃反复关押、殴打、绑在桌子上、性虐待并用刀割伤。其他陌生人也参与其中。巴尔博拉还声称
sometimes Andrei would stab her and beat her with a stick. Barbora's brother, Jan Szklar, said that he had seen evidence of injuries and abuse on Barbora's body. However, the eight independent psychologists and psychiatrists who assessed Barbora had concluded, quote, Barbora Shklova suffers from histrionic personality disorder which is accompanied by theatricality, dramatization, exaggerated expression of emotions, and manipulative behaviour to achieve one's own needs. The panel also believed Barbora's supposed history of seizures had been caused by convulsions associated with a disassociative disorder, not epilepsy. They determined that Barbora did not have multiple personality disorder, as she consciously and purposefully played the role of Anichka, and later Adam It was their opinion that for the purpose of the trial, Barbora was once again playing the role of a victim of a victim. As the trial drew to a close, Katerina Mauarova told the court that she could no longer sit quietly while accusations were made against Barbora. Katerina admitted
有时安德烈会刺伤她并用棍子打她。巴尔博拉的兄弟扬·什克拉尔说，他看到了巴尔博拉身上有受伤和虐待的痕迹。然而，评估巴尔博拉的八名独立心理学家和精神科医生得出结论：“巴尔博拉·什克洛娃患有表演型人格障碍，伴有戏剧性、夸张化、情绪表达夸张以及为达到自身需求而进行的操纵行为。”专家组还认为，巴尔博拉所谓的癫痫发作史是由与解离性障碍相关的惊厥引起的，而不是癫痫。他们确定巴尔博拉没有多重人格障碍，因为她是有意识且有目的地扮演阿尼奇卡的角色，后来又扮演亚当。他们的观点是，为了审判的目的，巴尔博拉再次扮演了受害者的角色。随着审判接近尾声，卡特琳娜·毛罗娃告诉法庭，她不能再在针对巴尔博拉的指控面前保持沉默。卡特琳娜承认
that in 2005 she introduced Barbora to her sister. She said that she had mistakenly called Barbora Anichka and referred to her as being younger. It was then Katerina helped Barbora develop the Anichka identity. Katerina encouraged Clara to bond with Anichka, though claimed that Clara allowed herself to be convinced by Anichka's story. Katerina denied Barbora ever participated in or influenced the abuse of Andrei and Yakub. She told the court that in the summer of 2006, she and Clara devised the punishments used against the boys based on instructions from a person she described as someone whom we trusted without limit. She wouldn't admit to writing the emails and text messages sent by Dr Andrei Zanarlov. Katerina claimed that the goal was to simply educate the boys, but that things got out of hand.
2005年，她将巴尔博拉介绍给了她的妹妹。她说她错误地称呼巴尔博拉为阿尼奇卡，并称她更年轻。正是那时，卡特琳娜帮助巴尔博拉发展了阿尼奇卡的身份。卡特琳娜鼓励克拉拉与阿尼奇卡建立联系，尽管她声称克拉拉让自己相信了阿尼奇卡的故事。卡特琳娜否认巴尔博拉曾参与或影响对安德烈和雅库布的虐待。她告诉法庭，2006年夏天，她和克拉拉根据一个她描述为“我们无限信任的人”的指示，设计了针对男孩们的惩罚措施。她不承认撰写了安德烈·扎纳洛夫医生发送的电子邮件和短信。卡特琳娜声称目标只是教育男孩们，但事情失控了。
During Katerina's testimony, Clara shouted at her sister, accusing her of lying and demanding to know why she had done this. Clara then collapsed and was removed from the courtroom. After Katerina finished her statement, she refused to answer any questions from the prosecution or the judge. In late October 2008, the six defendants were found guilty of all charges. For their role in the abuse, Jan Turek, Jan Szklar and Hanna Baszova were sentenced to five, seven and seven years in prison, respectively. The boy's mother, Klara Mauarova, was given nine years. Reflecting the leadership role she played, the boy's aunt, Katerina Mauarova, was sentenced to ten years.
在卡特琳娜作证期间，克拉拉对她的妹妹大喊大叫，指责她撒谎并要求知道她为什么要这样做。克拉拉随后晕倒并被带离法庭。卡特琳娜陈述完毕后，拒绝回答控方或法官的任何问题。2008年10月下旬，六名被告被判所有罪名成立。因在虐待中所扮演的角色，扬·图雷克、扬·什克拉尔和汉娜·巴绍娃分别被判处五年、七年和七年监禁。男孩的母亲克拉拉·毛罗娃被判处九年监禁。反映出她所扮演的领导角色，男孩的姨妈卡特琳娜·毛罗娃被判处十年监禁。
Barbora Szklova was given a 5-year sentence. All of the defendants except Clara appealed, and all were rejected. This crime, which has since come to be known as the Kurim case, remains surrounded by rumours and speculation. Despite messages from Dr Andrei Zanalov encouraging acts of cannibalism, there is no evidence that the abuse escalated that far. Although Andrei was filmed naked while in captivity, investigators believe this was purely for surveillance and not for sexual purposes. There was also speculation that Josef Schla, the father of Barbora and Jan, was involved in his children's crimes. Josef was once the leader of a Boy Scout group and according to one former member, he turned the group into an extremist sect. Under the guise of spiritual teachings, Yosef invented violent methods for
巴尔博拉·什克洛娃被判处五年监禁。除克拉拉外，所有被告都提出了上诉，但均被驳回。这起后来被称为“库里姆案件”的罪行，至今仍被谣言和猜测所包围。尽管有来自安德烈·扎纳洛夫医生的鼓励食人行为的信息，但没有证据表明虐待升级到了那种程度。虽然安德烈在被囚禁期间被拍下了裸照，但调查人员认为这纯粹是为了监视，而非出于性目的。还有人猜测，巴尔博拉和扬的父亲约瑟夫·什克拉尔参与了他孩子们的罪行。约瑟夫曾是一个童子军团的领袖，据一位前成员说，他把该团变成了一个极端主义教派。打着精神教导的幌子，约瑟夫发明了暴力方法来
breaking the scouts down in order to build them back up. Despite there being a similar motive in the treatment of Andrei and Yakub, Yosef Shklar hasn't been found to have any involvement in the Kurim case. Following the trial, Andrei and Yakub continue to be cared for at the Brone Children's Shelter. A court decision in December 2008 lifted the ban on visiting family members, and over time, the boys began to spend more and more time with their biological father and their maternal grandparents. By 2010, the boys lived with their grandparents full-time and were both doing well at school. All of the defendants served their minimum terms of imprisonment and were released on parole. None were permitted to work with children.
摧毁童子军，以便重新塑造他们。尽管在对待安德烈和雅库布的过程中有类似的动机，但没有发现约瑟夫·什克拉尔与库里姆案件有任何牵连。审判结束后，安德烈和雅库布继续在布尔诺儿童收容所接受照顾。2008年12月的一项法院裁决解除了禁止探视家庭成员的禁令，随着时间的推移，男孩们开始花越来越多的时间与他们的亲生父亲和外祖父母在一起。到2010年，男孩们与祖父母全职生活，在学校表现良好。所有被告都服完了最低刑期并获得假释。没有人被允许从事与儿童相关的工作。
Barbora Shklova was set free in February 2012 and changed her name soon after. News outlets reported she was living off a disability pension in an undisclosed location and was in the care of psychologists. Katerina Maurova was released in July 2014 and has kept a low profile since. Andrei and Yakub's mother, Klara Mauerova, left prison nine months before her sister. According to the court psychiatrist, Klara made impressive psychological progress during her incarceration and was not considered a danger to her children or the community. While she no longer had any custodial rights over her sons, Clara had worked on rebuilding her relationship with them while in prison. After some hesitation on Jakub's part, both he and Andrei wrote letters to her and visited regularly.
巴尔博拉·什克洛娃于2012年2月获释，此后不久改了名字。新闻媒体报道称，她靠残疾抚恤金生活在一个未公开的地点，并由心理学家照顾。卡特琳娜·毛罗娃于2014年7月获释，此后一直保持低调。安德烈和雅库布的母亲克拉拉·毛罗娃在她的妹妹获释前九个月离开了监狱。据法院精神科医生称，克拉拉在服刑期间取得了令人印象深刻的心理进步，不再被认为对她的孩子或社区构成危险。虽然她不再拥有对儿子的监护权，但克拉拉在狱中致力于重建与他们的关系。在雅库布犹豫了一段时间后，他和安德烈都给她写了信并定期探望她。
By the time Clara was released in October 2013, 15-year-old Jakub and 13-year-old Andrei were reportedly happy to have their mother back. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
到克拉拉于2013年10月获释时，据报道，15岁的雅库布和13岁的安德烈很高兴母亲回来。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。